so I I spoke to John Davis and John Fox
not too long ago and they told me they
were working on a documentary with you
um anyway yeah they've been doing that
documentary for
I did they they started that when I went
back to host Saturday Night Live
so what's that three years ago four
years it's been a while and I'm curious
what was it about what is it about this
doc that um that you said I'm gonna
allow myself to be filmed and I want to
you know tell my story
well I have been doing it so long you
know and there wasn't anything like that
and I've had a unique career so I was
like you know everybody does
documentaries now it's like um it's I
it's been I've been doing it long enough
and there's enough stuff that there's an
interesting story there like how it all
how it all happened you know and it's so
documented my last thing on it is there
like an end point that you see where
you're going to stop filming or is it
still being and the end was uh because
we had probably ended maybe three or
four months ago and was like Hey I'm
gonna get this uh
uh the Cecil B Demille award that's a
good way to end it so the end the end
will be that that winning that of
getting that award